you
[Music]
it's my real pleasure this morning to
introduce Chris Manning chris is the
Siebel professor of machine learning at
Stanford University where he has a joint
appointment in computer science and and
linguistics reflecting his broad and
multidisciplinary background he's also
the director of the Stanford AI lab and
is one of the folks on the Advisory
Board of a new human centered AI
initiative at Stanford so you can see
the breadth of his his influence at
Stanford and be well beyond that he's
very very well known for his work on
statistical natural language processing
ranging from more linguistic
perspectives on parsing and grammar
induction to more machine learning
perspectives including his recent work
on glove and and many other techniques
that leverage large scale data to solve
very interesting problems chris is
amazingly well known in many different
communities he has over a hundred
thousand citations he you can figure out
how many that is per waking hours since
he publishes his first paper it's
probably more than one but another part
of his influence I think goes above and
beyond his his research that spans both
spans language artificial intelligence
machine learning information retrieval
he's a fellow of all three of the major
societies in computer science
linguistics and AI but he's also
contributed to the field in many other
ways he's the author a co-author of two
really important books on one on the
foundations of statistical NLP and
another on in modern information
retrieval but he's also with his
students develop many tools that are
shared how many have used the stanford
parser at their sanford NLP tools he
shared code of all kinds he shared
representations things that arose out of
his work on glove and so chris i think
is a real scholar in many senses of that
that word what
going to do today is talk to us about
how we can go right now if you look at
language and representations many of
them focus on understanding the
relationships among words similarity
structures and in words but he's going
to talk much more broadly about how we
can bring notions of memory attention
compositionality and reasoning to
develop systems that have much more
intelligence than many of our current
systems so Chris without further ado
thanks ok good morning and thank you
soon for that very kind introduction I
hope I can live up to it and takes to
everyone for coming to the talk yeah so
today what I want to do is talk about
some of our recent work on trying to
build neural networks that can reason
and this is joint work with my student
drew Hudson so our current neural
network machine learning systems truly
excel on a variety of tasks such as
speech recognition and computer vision
and interestingly they've even been
pushed with surprising success to other
tasks which you'd think
involve higher-level reasoning and
understanding a notable success has been
the development of neural machine
translation which has worked exceedingly
well but in some sense even neural
machine translation has approached
things as a stimulus-response task that
your provider here's the input sentence
produce the output as a kind of a
statistical Association task so these
kind of tasks don't require deliberate
thinking or reasoning the kind of
processes that Daniel Kahneman has
referred to as thinking slow so what can
we do about reasoning reasoning is
central to figuring out a good approach
when humans are faced with a new problem
in developing longer-term plans for
higher-level objective can we use new
networks to do the kind of model
libera conscious multistep thought so
that might be things like middle school
style reading comprehension problems
which aren't really like what most of
the current reading comprehension
question-answering datasets are like but
much more understanding a broad
understanding of the characters and what
they're doing in a novel common sense
reasoning and problem solving working
out plans playing a strategic game but
tast like this we really need a better
notions of having knowledge reasoning
and inference so what then is reasoning
how can reasoning which has
traditionally been thought of in
connection with logics and hand-built
knowledge representations be learned by
the kind of distributed representation
computation units of deep learning
so one inspiring viewpoint on this was
provided by Leon Batu in 2011 who
suggested that the heart of reasoning is
having the means for algebraically
manipulating previously acquired
knowledge in order to answer new
questions so but to suggested that we
could seek to enhance deep learning
systems with reasoning capabilities by
from the ground up that reasoning is not
necessarily achieved by making logical
inferences that he saw a kind of
continuity between algebraic
algebraically rich inferences and
connecting together trainable learning
components and in particularly
emphasized that central to reasoning is
composition rules to guide the
combinations of modules to address new
tasks and so one of the things I'm want
to think about today is how can we start
to build composition rules for
multi-step reasoning in neural networks
and so underlying this is some kind of a
conception as to where things might head
in deep learning so in some sense the
dominant viewpoint in the deep world
community is to seek a learning device
that is as empty as possible some kind
of tabula rasa and so what's happened in
a lot of recent work is that the
emptiness of the machine learning device
is compensated for by providing extra
information in the input so a very
successful technique in recent years has
been data augmentation so effectively
you're providing lots of extra inputs on
a vision system you rotate the images a
little and shave off a few pixels and
change the coloration and things like
this where you're saying all of that
your model you want to build should be
invariant to all of those things however
I believe that we shouldn't be afraid of
good inductive biases of thinking about
how we could design our neural network
systems so that they're built so that
they have the ability to learn quickly
and well and that probably having that
kind of architectures some architectural
constraints is vital to how human beings
are able to learn so quickly and well
indeed I think the biggest breakthroughs
and deep learning have come from
building the right kind of inductive
biases sort of structural priors into
models now of course you can fail if you
build models with too rigid structure
but we succeed by finding appropriate or
flexible structural priors
so these successes include convolutions
which have been central to work
envisioned the notion of attention which
has been very central to a lot of the
recent advances in natural language
processing in other areas also the kind
of gating that you find in LST m's or
highway networks is again building in a
good structural prior into your models
in my early deep learning work I was a
strong proponent of the idea of tree
structured compositional models I
believe that that gave the right
inductive bias for many human language
tasks and also some other some
in other domains so the model was that
you would take pairs of vectors which
would initially be vector
representations of words and then you'd
build from that a vector representation
of a phrase like very good here and then
you could continue applying the same
pairwise composition operation
recursively and you could build up
representations of phrases and sentences
and we were able to apply this model
with some success to various tasks
including sentiment analysis so here the
model could start reading the sentence
there are slow and repetitive parts and
start to build up a composed structure
where it says well that's a negative
impression but it has just enough spice
to keep it interesting and it builds up
a representation where that part of the
symptoms is positive and the positivity
wins out so that overall this is a
positive thing to say about a movie and
these models aren't only applicable to
language you can actually apply the same
ideas and vision so that visual scenes
also commonly have a compositional
structure and so in these experiments
that we did on the Stanford background
data said that it's building up a
compositional representation of a church
from the pieces of the building and is
using that to understand this visual
scene interestingly what botter suggests
in 2011 as a model for reasoning was
essentially exactly the same kind of
tree structure and recursive neural
network that we started employing for
natural language he proposed that the
path to universal composition was that
you built an association module a in
this picture from his paper that maps to
representations taken from memory into a
new representation of the same sort and
that that new representation can be
scored by module R in this picture a guy
in France and simultaneously the new
representation can be put back into the
short
memory where it can be used recursively
to build up a proof tree however for
reasons of partly computational
efficiency and partly limitations and
flexibility it turns out that tree
structured composition hasn't really won
out in neural network research in the
last five years but there are
alternatives so one that I already
mentioned was this idea of attention I
mean if you look at it you can think of
attention as almost trees by another
name because we're effectively putting a
sort of a soft tree structure over the
previous nodes to generate a
representation of the next node and we
can apply that recursively as we work
building up along the sequence but we
now have sort of soft weights rather
than a rigid tree structure you cannot a
second alternative for building up
something like the two's function that
takes multiple arguments is to think
that maybe our neural networks could do
what logicians call carrying so rather
than having multi-argument functions
like f that's taking three arguments X Y
Z we could instead build intermediate
compositions so we can take one argument
at a time like X and build an
intermediate representation or function
which can then take the next argument Y
and proceed to build up an overall
representation and it seems reasonable
to assume that neural sequence models
could do this kind of computation so in
this current line of work the hope is
that we could start exploring your
network architectures so that rather
than having big fairly unstructured
neural networks that act as Association
engines or correlation engines that look
just for any kind of patterning in the
import we could use a model that is more
structured with the prior that
encourages compositional and
and spirit multi-step reasoning however
we'd like to do this in models that are
still practically usable and so for the
models that we've built we've focused on
models they're still into n
differentiable there's a ton of work now
on building reinforcement learning
models in which this is not true but I
still see it I still see the simplicity
of entering differential models as so
much easier to train and work with and
also it provides us in a space where
it's easy to build models that are still
scalable to reasonably large problems so
in the work today I'm going to
concentrate on showing results from the
area of visual question-answering so
here we've shown a picture and we asked
questions about it and the suggestion is
that asking questions is a good way to
assess understanding this was a
viewpoint that was put forward very
early on so long ago there used to be
the Yale AI school who here is old
enough to have heard of the Yale AI
school yeah that's about three people
and so what members of the Yale AI
school was Wendy Leonard who worked on
question answering and she writes when a
person understands the story they can
demonstrate their understanding by
answering questions about the story
since questions can be devised to query
any aspect of text comprehension the
ability to answer questions is the
strongest possible demonstration of
understanding the same is true for
visual scenes and what I've been
interested in visual question answering
is because it's just seemed like a
better proving ground for compositional
reasoning although there has been a ton
of work which I've also been involved in
in doing textural question answering
systems in general the textual question
answering work has still been dominated
by lexical semantics matching and there
just hasn't been very much
opportunity to
multi-step iterative reasoning and that
domain where it seemed like visual
question answering gave a kind of a nice
place ground to be looking at multi-step
compositional reasoning ok so that's my
intro I'm trying to go from Xin learning
to machine reading and so for the rest
of the talk today I first of all want to
tell you about our initial work on Mac
networks on the clever task and tell you
a little bit about a new dataset gqa
that we've developed more recently the
visual question-answering and then tell
you about more fresh off the press
Newell state machine model and they're
doing visual question-answering ok so
let's just start off with the clever
data said so the clever data set came
out of considerations of visual
question-answering and so the belief of
some of the people working in visual
question-answering that that the the
most used visual question-answering
tasks which came from Bartra and per
weeks group at georgia tech that it had
sort of led to some kind of research on
language and vision but it hadn't really
been a very good testing ground for
actually doing scene understanding and
compositional reasoning and so justin
johnson and colleagues at face book AI
research decided that they should try
and come up with a diagnostic data set
that especially focused on compositional
language and visual reasoning about
scenes and so they went back to this old
classic of AI blocks world and so they
synthesized block world scenes in
blender and then they asked long
compositional questions about these
scenes so in this one there is a purple
cube there are some purple cubes but
this one is behind a metal object
there's a metal object so that seems it
has to be this purple cube that is left
to a large ball well there's a large
ball and it's left of it
that seems hopeful what material is the
cube and if you haven't seen this data
set before you'd probably say no idea
but it turns out in this data set all
things are made out of two materials
they do that metal or rubber so if
they're not shiny the right answer is
rubber okay and so a number of people
have worked on systems to approach this
data set but as well as the scene and
the question and answer another
attribute of this data set which was
there if reflection as to how it was
constructed that on the right hand side
there's a sort of informal
representation of a functional program
so the way that this data set was
constructed was that they were building
functional programs that they could run
on these data on the visual scenes in an
abstracted form and get out of them the
answer and then that functional program
was converted into natural language and
so one of the questions on using this
data set then will come up again later
is are you just building a system over
just textual questions and answers and
images or are you making use of these
this functional program as added
supervision so one of the example of a
piece of work that has made use of the
functional program has been a line of
work by Jakob andreas and then by Justin
Johnson himself that has explored Newell
module networks so these are partially
differentiable models that try to
approach the problem composition way but
they rely on the strong supervision of
the functional program to translate
queries into a tree structured
functional program so that the first
part of the model is LST M
encoder/decoder model that reads the
textual question and
juices the functional program and then
the second part of that is another
neural network which interprets this
functional program so that neural
network is built out of custom building
blocks for these different semantic
operations so there's counting neural
network and the comparing neural network
and a filtering neural network and
they're plugged together in a
compositional way and they interpret
this functional program and then aim to
give the answer from it okay but what I
want to do first today is to introduce
our version of approaching this problem
which is the Mac Network which stood for
memory attention composition as a neural
model for problem solving and reasoning
tasks so we want to have this idea of
building a network with structure that
encourages it to do multi-step reasoning
so it should decompose a problem into a
sequence of explicit reasoning steps and
each of them as corresponds to one Mac
cell in our network but on the other
hand it didn't seem right to us the kind
of neural module Network approach that I
just showed on the previous slide that
it seemed much too bespoke by the time
you were custom designing individual
Network units for comparison filtering
counting and things like that that
didn't seem sufficiently generic as a
model of intelligence so what we wanted
is one universal Mac cell that could be
used to be for everything and it's
versatile enough that it can learn to do
different things depending on the
context in which it's applied and what
we're building is a recurrent neural
network but the recurrent neural network
is able to have attention backwards
throughout a sequence of reasoning steps
and so through attention it can a soft
way represent a complex reasoning graph
and but in a model that still has end to
end differentiability
and so each Maxell is sort of one step
of a reasoning system and so the design
we had is of a more articulated design
than most standard recurrent neural
networks since it the model retains two
recurrent states so it has a control
state which is used to describe the
reasoning operation of the network and
the control state is an attention based
average of a given query which in our
case is just the textual question and
then there's a memory state which is
based on information which in general
we'd say is being collected from a
knowledge base that in the particular
application here the knowledge base is
simply the image that the system is
looking at and so the memory is going to
be represented as an attention based
average over our image or over our
knowledge base so there are a couple of
things that are worth at least noting
here one is that in our model we're not
going to make use of the strong
supervision of the functional programs
at all we're simply working from the
question and the picture and attempting
to get the answer the other one is this
design choice that we're representing
thinking in terms of attention so
attention based averages over given
query and attention based averages over
the image the second model I show later
does things a bit differently and has
more abstraction we'll get to that later
but it also represents everything as
attention based averages and I can't
prove anything here this is just a bet
but it seemed to us that the use of
attention based models of this sort has
proved to be very successful and an
immediate good property of these kind of
models is that attention gives the kind
of easy interpret ability you can say
what words is the model looking at and
what part of the picture is the model
looking at but beyond that it seems that
by grounding our models in the space of
attention
Everage --is that that's appears to be a
a useful way to somehow constrain and
direct the models and get them to learn
more effectively than if we just have
unconstrained hidden states okay and
slightly more detail so here is our Mac
cell so on the top part of the Mac cell
we have the control unit which computes
a control state so it takes in the
question text and the previous control
state and we'll generate a new control
state by focusing on some aspect of the
query and then down in the bottom we
have the memory so this part takes in a
preceding memory hidden state and our
so-called knowledge base here the image
and based on the control information and
the previous memory State it reads some
information out of the knowledge base or
image and then that generates a new
candidate memory which is combined with
preceding memories to generate a new MI
memory unit which is then written into
the next memory State merging old and
new information and so the bet here is
at the time we first started this work
there had been some quite prominent work
from deep mind on neural Turing machines
and then differentiable neural computers
and it seemed that although you know in
theory those models were very powerful
it seemed like in practice they were
very difficult to control and indeed I
think to this day they haven't been
demonstrated on any larger scale
problems and part of the different he
comes from the sort of Turing machine
style arbitrariness if you can read and
write anywhere and that makes it very
difficult to learn and control these
models whereas this model has a very
simple or
ionization since your sequentially
laying down memories but each next
memory can be done based on attention
over previous memories
let's see time goes by fast so I
probably should do this quickly so I get
on to the later ones okay very quickly
more details in the paper okay so the
control part takes the previous control
straight and the query it computes a
representation it then uses attention on
to the words of the well actually I
should explain that for the words of the
question there run through a
bi-directional lsdm so they're sort of
contextual words so it then uses what
it's computed up here
to put attention over the words of the
query in the standard attention
distribution way to produce a weighted
average over the words of the queries
and normally focusing on certain words
and that gives the next time steps
control signal for the read unit that's
taking in the previous memory state and
the knowledge base the picture and then
it is wanting to get something out of
the image and the early part of that
allows the previous memory to interact
with the image and get stuff out of it
in an associative way and then it feeds
in the control state and does the second
round of using that to put attention
over the image and again we have a
weighted weighted based on attention
retrieval from the image and that
creates the new memory state and so then
with also the new candidate memory state
so for the new candidate memory state
that then goes into the light unit and
so the new candidate rent memory stayed
then itself is combined with past memory
States
using the control stayed so the control
is used to feed which past memory states
to pay attention to in a kind of a
key-value attention mechanism and so
that is then used to calculate a sort of
a weighted distribution over previous
memories their new memory and that that
then gives you the new memory state and
the hope is that we can simulate in that
way doing a kind of a soft but arbitrary
dag of reasoning of successively writing
new memory states so that's one Maxell
and then we build a Mac Network by
building a recurrent sequence model that
runs through a bunch of those cells and
that gives us a model that's efficient
easy to deploy and still fully
differentiable but it has the capacity
to represent arbitrarily complex
reasoning via directed acyclic graphs in
a soft way through attention okay so let
me provide present the results of this
in terms of the initially the clever
data set so it had 700,000 training
examples 150,000 test examples the space
of answers is very small there's metal
rubber cube sphere few colors very small
numbers 0 1 2 3 4 5 so the baseline is
quite high so if you answer the most
frequent answer by question type you're
already at almost 42 percent but what
they'd wanted to show is that this kind
of architectures that had been used for
visual question answering sort of CN n
stacks plus L STM's didn't really work
on this data because they didn't do the
necessary reasoning so kind of a
state-of-the-art
bqa system at this time a couple of
years ago only got 52 percent compared
to that neural module networks
Jacob and Reza's work did a ton better
God 83% which was not too far off the
92.6% that was reported as human
accuracy um but you know actually these
problems were synthesized right so there
are synthesized images and synthesized
answers based on the functional programs
so there's absolutely no reason why
system shouldn't be able to get a
hundred percent on this data and there's
a sort of actually a fairly artificial
reason why human performance was
depressed from a hundred percent not
just human laziness and so actually
what's happened in more recent work was
sort of all of the action moved to the
ninety five to a hundred percent space
and so initially deep mind came up with
a relation network model that got to
95.4% then Justin Johnson did a new
generation of neural module networks
that got to almost 97 percent people and
Montreal with the film network got to
ninety seven point seven percent and so
relation networks and film are
essentially both large CN n stacks
interleaved with specialized layers so
relation Nets had a relation net layer
where every pair of pixels has
relationships assessed between it to
understand binary relations film inserts
these conditional linear normalization
layers that tilt the activations based
on the question is how'd it get insured
of sense about that model does but
anyway our mac network works super well
it gives 98.9% which essentially halves
the remaining error but you might be
starting to wonder how meaningful this
is and thinking so close to a hundred
percent so something that i think is
interesting is the following that if we
look at learning curves based on how
much training data you give
to the models and if use instead of
giving the model 700,000 examples
you only give them 70,000 training
examples then what you do is find that
other models such as the film model or
the new module network model of Justin
Johnson they can't actually learn very
much from 70,000 examples at all even if
70,000 was a lot right this isn't a very
big space you think you shouldn't have
to learn something from you know 70 here
100 and examples that they sort of don't
get that far above baseline performance
and most common classes whereas our
magnet model is already getting 86
percent accuracy over 70,000 examples so
I think that's actually an interesting
proof that the design of the model has
the right kind of priors to be solving
these kind of multi-step inference
problems now the subsequent work Justin
Johnson also built a clever humans
dataset where he collected 18,000 who
were your questions from humans through
crowdsourcing where they're told to
write questions hard for a smart robot
to answer and so these questions have a
more diverse vocabulary different kinds
of reasonings skills which might not be
in the original data set and there's a
small training set for fine-tuning so if
you run with the original data zero shot
on this clever humans data set you get
these results when none of the systems
work great but magnet does do a little
bit better if you fine-tune on the
training set you get these results where
again the mac net is able to get more
value from the the fine-tuning set than
any of the other models again I think
reflecting its ability to generalize
well from small amounts of data and
starts to get quite good performance
now here's sort of a couple of examples
that show how we get the benefits of
having interpretable reasoning from
having the attention over both the
sentence and our image so what color is
the map thing to the right of the sphere
front of the teeny blue block so this is
a very short example where there are
these three reasoning steps
so on the first reasoning step it
focuses on teeny blue block in the
language and looks at the teeny blue
block in the second reasoning step it's
the sphere in front and it's then
focusing in the image on the sphere in
front and then third reasoning step is
color is the map thing and it's going to
the map thing and asking its color and
correctly answers purple you get better
results for longer sequence of reasoning
so here's it using six reasoning steps
on this example how many objects are
either small objects behind that tiny
metal cylinder or metallic cubes in
front of the large green metal object
and often what you see here is in the
first couple of time steps in more sort
of looks at the macro structure of what
it's being asked before it starts to
focus visually so initially it's looking
at the how many the question type and
well either small I'm not sure what it's
doing there but then the second step is
realizing it's sort of a disjunction
between two things and then in the third
time step it starts focusing on
particular things so large green metal
is looking at the large green metal
metallic cubes and it's looking at the
metallic cubes teeny metal cylinder and
looking at that small objects behind
things at any rate it's not quite clear
how it does the counting but it does in
this example correctly if the answer of
four so I guess it's managed to somehow
get that out of the what's going on okay
so that was an initial
neuro compositional reasoning engine and
so I hope I've shown that it seems like
we've gone some good value from having a
constrained sequence model with good
priors separated out control and memory
and exploiting attention but let me move
on and get to the newer stuff okay so
one problem is that although there were
these early
using datasets including clever they
seem kind of limited there's artificial
images and/or language there's a very
small space of possible objects and
attributes and so although in theory
you're doing compositional reasoning the
feeling is that because the amount of
data is so large and the space is so
small that the suspicion is that these
models actually just memorize molecules
so they just learn what a red metal
sphere is and that they therefore they
have a lot less compositionality in them
than you'd hope they have on the other
hand the main visual question-answering
benchmarks have also seemed somewhat
problematic so there are strong what are
often referred to as language biases but
i think it's mainly actually more
real-world biases and models guess based
on priors so snow covers the ground the
grass is green and things like that
there's also visual biases to overly say
land salient objects and it's hard to
tell when systems are going wrong what
exactly is causing it and really the
questions are too simple the questions
are often simply what color is the grass
so little reasoning or compositionality
is required and so and we've worked to
produce this new data set for
compositional question answering over
real world in images called gqa and in
some sense this is clever done on a
larger scale so we've generated we Tet
start with real images which come from
the same MS Coco sources and everybody
uses in the vision world and then
generate questions involving sort of
compositional questions a bit like
clever and so we generate 10 million
compositional questions overall and then
generate a balance smaller set of
questions with closely controlled answer
distributions and the way we do that is
that we make use of
and provide a scene graph with each
image that represents its semantics and
then the questions like in clever come
with a functional program grounded in
the scene graph that shows that
semantics perhaps surprisingly the
questions we build are generated using a
traditional rule-based question engine
but you know this means that it's sort
of just so the precise semantics that a
rule-based system can give you that
we're just sort of turning the scene
graph representation in a very
controlled manner into question natural
language questions are still a
controlled language but we tried to give
much more in the way of linguistic
diversity and a large vocabulary and
since we totally can understand the
scenes and we can have metrics that can
assess the consistency and model the
answers and various other metrics okay
so in slightly more detail our starting
off point is the visual genome data set
that my Stanford colleagues are on Jai
Krishna and Michael Bernstein Fei Fei Li
and others developed where you're
staying off at the MS koko pictures and
then they're putting over this a scene
graph representations shown at rise
where there are identified objects which
are the pink things like helmet watch
and man these objects can have
attributes silver helmet black watch and
then they can be connected together by
relationship so the man is wearing a
helmet or the cow is kneeling on the
grass we produce the sort of improved
visual genome so rather than just
bounding boxes we made use of the last
few years and computer vision technology
and now have maths over images but more
importantly the original scene graphs
are completely unrestrained in their
natural language labeling of things so
we move to a clear ontology of concepts
by resolving synonyms
discarding some very unclear or rare
things so our ontology has 1,700 objects
600 attributes and 330 relations which
are grouped into 60 categories and
sub-categories we also augment the
graphs with some additional information
we put in positional relation
information some kind of comparative
information of same or different color
and some other global information that
seems useful but intend to be in the
scene graphs thinks about the weather
and things like that ok so then once we
have these scene graphs we generate
using our rule-based engine natural
language questions and you know this is
a conventional rule-based natural
language generation system with
probabilistic rules so we can have sort
of common and uncommon patterns with a
sort of standard kind of context free
style grammar that can build up
descriptions there's then kind of quite
a lot of work behind the scenes which is
then trying to make these questions be
good questions so we want to make sure
they're answerable they're uniquely
answer a ball and that they seem
reasonably natural so that you know
they're sort of actually then a lot of
large somewhat induced somewhat
hand-built lexico that underlie what
kind of words and natural words to use
to describe various kinds of
relationships then lightly more
abstractly expressed in the scene graph
and this gives you an idea of the
differences between DQ a and G QA so
visual question answering has sort of
crowdsource questions and crowd sourced
answers in unrestricted natural language
so you know the V QA questions are real
human questions whereas g QA the
questions are more artificial because
we're generating them from our grammar
on the other hand the g QA questions we
believe her a better testbed for
exploring c
understanding and reasoning because the
vqa questions are sort of sort of random
does this man need a haircut what is
different about the man's shirt that
shows this is for a special occasion and
rely on a lot of sort of world knowledge
that you can't really answer things from
the question our our questions are sort
of more straightforward seeing
understanding questions which are
perhaps more artificial sounding is
there a necktie in the picture there's
not red but we're at least we're
thinking that this is probably a sort of
a better testbed for exploring visual
understanding and compositional
reasoning than vqa has provided and you
know this isn't a one is better this is
sort of better for a certain purpose
kind of an answer here are the baseline
accuracies that we got with this new
data set so global prior is if you're
just saying if you're asking a color
question you give the most common color
answer you get whatever about 17% this
is a vision only model so there's been a
tradition vqa of seeing how far you can
get with a vision only model or a
language only model the local prior is
prior prior for a particular kind of
object so this is if you're asking what
color is the Apple you do rather better
than the global prior the El STM is the
language only model and this is the
result has always been shown in current
vqa systems that you can do not terribly
by ignoring the picture altogether and
just answering based on the language
that you're given LST m plus CNN is sort
of the standard baseline bqa system
bottom-up is the recent kind of winning
the QA systems of Peter Anderson and
colleagues that use bottom-up and
top-down attention if you look really
closely you'll notice that our Mac model
was better than any of these other
models but somewhat disappointingly
the Mac model doesn't actually work
very well this data set is trying to
prove the point a more abstract
reasoning and it's way below humans that
are coming in at about 90% accuracy so
in the last bit of the talk I then want
to tell you a bit about a new model that
we've been exploring that tries to do
somewhat better than this and so now the
thing that we've been exploring this new
model is so for visual question
answering well question and answers are
clearly about language but maybe we
could actually make more progress on
visual question answering rather than
having these systems which have vision
on one side and language on the other
side if we instead represented what
we're doing for visual question
answering is doing everything in terms
of an internal language of thought so
what we'd like to do is have a common
conceptual representation which we can
represent both language which we use to
represent both language expressions and
visual scenes in and then we'll be able
to reason using that and we'll be able
to do better ok so I am no expert on
human visual perception but nevertheless
my superficial understanding of human
visual perception is the idea that
brains have a photo of in their brain
that they're using isn't supported by
most of what's in human visual
perception instead that you know eyes
are making momentary fixations and what
they're getting out of each fixation is
some kind of very high-level seen gist
right so you do a fixation on the man
and you see there's a man who looks like
a cyclist with neo glasses helmet gloves
watch and you're sort of aware of the
fact there's a grassland scene with a
cow somewhere off to the right but you
know you don't actually get a lot of
detail out of that and then you'll sort
of Sicard make another fixation and
maybe you look at the cow and then you
Motors has horns and a bell on the front
or something like that but it's really
that so they're fairly abstracted seen
just as what's actually in the brain as
you do this visual processing so in the
same way our hope is that we can use
concepts to organize our visual sensory
experience and we can build from those a
kind of an abstraction a world model to
represent what we're seeing in our
environment and our world models will
essentially be the scene graphs that I
just showed you and that those we'll be
able to use those to draw inferences and
so this is sort of fits in with the
general deep learning story so the hope
of deep learning models is that we could
use the depth to learn higher level
abstractions and the reason why that
should be useful is that for surface
signals like visual signals there's all
sorts of complications and variations
but if we can build a higher level
abstractions we should be able to
disentangle our representations and that
will allow us to improve generalization
and so in particular the way we want to
do that is by building a model that does
content-based attention over concepts so
attention is our central operation again
that we're using here so we're going to
have a large set of concepts and we're
going to put attention over a few
concepts and crucially what we're going
to explore here is previously in the
most other vision systems you're putting
attention directly over the image over
pixel space but here it's arguing that
maybe if instead we can put our visual
attention over concept space we'll be
able to do rather better where concept
space is our language of thought so this
is sort of related to what yoshua bengio
has proposed as is so called
consciousness prior I'm not sure I like
that name but I think the idea is
basically right so the general research
program is to say that we should try and
learn deep representations that
disentangle
explanatory factors and then his
suggestion is that conscious state is a
very low dimensional vector which is
sort of an attention mechanism over the
disentangled deep representation the way
we're doing things is somewhat different
what he proposes but in some sense it's
a sort of same ideas of disentangle
concept space putting attention over it
and so this is a model of the neural
state machine so we have a vocabulary of
embedded concepts which are our atomic
semantic units and that is now cleaned
up visual genome ontology that I told
you about earlier and then but this time
we're going to translate both questions
and images into these concepts so that
they both speak the same language so
everything is going to be represented as
a tension over concept vocabulary and so
we hope that this will give us sort of a
model of concept learning and use
somewhat similar to what humans might do
okay so in your state machine is a
differentiable graph based model which
simulates a state machine and so in some
sense we're hoping to see it combining
some of the strengths of both neural and
traditional symbolic approaches and so
this is what we do we've got two stages
of construction and in France so in the
construction stage we are going to take
image and turn it into a scene graph and
so the way we're doing this is following
other work that's done image two scene
graph and again including work by Ron
Jai Krishna and others at Stanford we're
using similar methods to generate scene
graphs from images we do object
recognition and then have for the
components that infer relationship like
attributes of objects and relations
between objects and simultaneously we
run encoder/decoder style morale over
the natural language question and turn
into a sequence of instructions which
are at
tension over concepts in our abstracted
concept space and then we're going to do
inference which is going to be a state
machine style computation over our graph
to compute an answer so you know
formally we have something that looks
like a finite state machine with States
and edges then there are kind of a
sequence of instructions that are going
to be sort of like an input but we're
going to do things in probabilistic
manner so we start with the probability
distribution over initial States and
then we have a neural state transition
function which computes probabilities of
next States based on the current state
distribution and what the instruction is
okay so this is it all pictorially so
from an image we construct a scene graph
which happens to also look like a state
machine where the states correspond
objects' and the transitions correspond
to relations and the states have these
properties and all of this is
represented in the soft way as attention
over concepts in our concept ontology
and so effectively these attentions over
concepts give us a disentangled
representation in terms of concepts and
their properties and relations between
them so it's all factorized using our
concept vocabulary the question is then
also translated into a series of
instructions and so each instruction is
again an attention distribution over
concepts but if we just go with the Arg
max of it what is the red fruit inside
of the bowl to the right of the
coffeemaker gets interpreted to
instruction sequence of coffeemaker
right ball inside red and so then we can
run these instructions on our state
machine and say well start with the
coffeemaker you want to look to the
right there should be a bowl there you
want to look inside that
and there's something red and the
network will then be able to say oh yeah
that's an apple and will then be able to
answer the question correctly now here's
one more example of that so what is the
tall object the left of the bed made of
so the model will form the instruction
sequence bed left tall made and so at
all first of all the looking at the bed
looking to the left of the bed
confirming this something tall there
then asking what it's made of and will
turn the answer red but you know I'm
just sort of doing this as sort of one
hot one hot language and describing it
really at each stage this is done as
sort of soft attention distributions and
at all times there's a soft a soft
activation level over the entire of the
scene graph um so here's our new model
so this is over gqa again so these were
all the models I already talked about
and Mac and so we are actually getting a
nice lift there from the neural state
machine model which is now working quite
a bit better um fine point you'll notice
um max doing a bit better than before as
well yeah it turns out if you turn these
models for longer outweighs them do a
bit better nevertheless in neural state
machine is doing kind of well better
than that and I hope that that's sort of
showing that you know working having
reduced things both to the language of
concepts gives you some power here a
couple more demonstrations so there's
another interesting data set that was
done good to know I shower go ow and
colleagues from Georgia Tech where they
wanted to sort of give a better test of
visual question-answering than standard
vqa data set so they produced this vq
acp data set where the
liberally the distribution was changed
between the training set and the test
set so for example the training set for
what sport is at questions the two most
common answers were tennis and baseball
that they changed the distributions on
the test set the most common sports
showing the skiing then baseball soccer
I'm skateboarding etc so you have a
different distribution and so if you've
actually an understanding concepts you
should be able to still get the answer
right but if you're just guessing based
on world priors you'll get the answers
badly wrong and so what they showed was
most current models you can see here
here are the neural module networks that
we talked about before again and various
other models at that point it seemed
like well no actually they weren't
understanding concepts and so many of
these models their performance
essentially halfed when you went to the
vq acp data set
okay so sector tension networks perform
terribly on this data set so I'll go out
without produce their own model that
worked better and I'm interesting this
was actually also a model that mapped
both images and language to concepts so
they sort of had that idea as well then
here are all the 2019 models on archive
which are doing rather better than their
model but again with the neural state
machine model
I think we're getting additional power
by having this state machine then we can
simulate reasoning on I have one more
example of that but time is going by so
maybe I should skip do you want I don't
have many slides left so I could do this
example then okay I will so we can do
the same kind of thing with gqa that
since we do have scene graphs and
functional programs behind all of gqa we
can also do the same trick that they did
of changing distributions so we can
check we can have distinctions
instructor
between training and testing so we can
have the training only using some
linguistic constructs for the notion of
covering or what something is made of
and at testing doing different kinds of
questions or we can have different
content so at training we can not have
any questions that refer to types of
foods or animals and a testing time we
do have questions of that sort and the
fine point here is I mean it's not the
thing we don't have you know completely
novel object so it's not that we're sort
of asking it test time what's this
animal and there's a red panda it never
saw a red panda at training time so far
objects in isolation we've got our
trained object detector which has seen
all of the objects that map onto our
concept vocabulary in the training data
but that's only sort of learning in
isolation so this is sort of saying can
it compose together that knowledge to be
able to answer new kinds of questions
that it hadn't been asked about at
training time and so here are our
results here and again you know the Mac
Network will argue as a bit along the
right lines but the neuro state machine
is much more effectively being able to
generalize these new types of questions
where some of the sort of more standard
bqa models you know it's not that they
don't work at all but perform fairly
poorly at generalizing to new types of
things like this
so in conclusion yeah so so the QA is a
problem has always been considerably
about language but I think it might be
interesting to explore whether you can
think in terms of a conceptual space or
a language of thought where you use
their common representation for
different modalities for reasoning about
and that my
actually give additional power and I've
outlined a model that did that I mean in
general I think there's this sort of
exciting question how can we take our
neural network models have been so
successful for sensory perception tasks
and work out whether we can also use
them for thinking slow tasks involving
understanding and multi-step
compositional reasoning then so the
overall goal is can we build neural
networks that think and I think there's
actually a reasonable hope that we might
be able to do that and I've suggested
that at least one promising direction
has been to do this by trying to build
models which use attention over
abstracted disentangled concepts and
then do multi-step reasoning by having
an iterative attention process over
different time steps thank you
my experience fabulous and provoking
talk why don't we spend the next 10 or
15 minutes answering questions and then
give you a little bit of a break before
you head off tune in all these
compositional reasoning intersect one
thing that's clearly missing is
hierarchy to any show the picture of all
these people neck tall woman short boy
and man came up to me with the family
but family was never mentioned in the
scene actually family so do you think
yes I mean I guess yeah I mean so I
think that's a completely valid
observation and outside the question was
these models are doing some kind of
multi-step reasoning yes that they're
not representing hierarchy or perhaps
not even really representing
compositionality and it seems like they
should I mean that actually goes back to
this early picture I showed right there
right I think there's no doubt at all
that there's lots of need to represent
composition hierarchy because so a lot
of the time
yes we're sort of thinking in terms of
these hierarchical models where we're
sort of seeing bigger composite holes
and I agree we haven't really been
addressing that but I I think we should
we sort of did in this old work in 2011
maybe we'll get back to one of these
days the testing methodology so at the
end you should have you know if the
distribution on the training and the
testing was different you'd get you know
a worse result is there any effort to
like systematically test by every
possible you know object of the scene or
you know it seems like you could be
since you're generating these queries
and these scenes you know automatically
you just systematically generate all the
possible inputs
right I mean so so yeah I mean that's
sort of not something I talked about but
I mean that's actually one of the things
that we aim I guess oh swears down here
not very explained very well on that
last point I mean that was something
that we saw as one of the big advantages
of this sort of having the controlled
questions of gqa that we can generate
lots of questions which are effectively
answering the same or related things you
know so we can our serve what color is
the go-kart is the go-kart red is the
go-kart green and we could assess
automatically whether a system is giving
consistent answers and it turns out that
a lot of the time the QA systems don't
give consistent answers and you know if
you do that for relational ones as well
we could take what is to the left of the
go card and maybe there's a person then
we can say what are some right of the
person and ask backwards and so on so
and so better assess actual
understanding rather than random
guessing and so we actually have some
metrics that we define that look at
consistency of answering and have gotten
some results on that yeah so I have a
question about state and your state
marshal and currently I think you have
117 or 1070 kind of object and the day
of the week on the mission on such a
night for cavalry of judges
I think performance should be very bad
so I I think it's the I question about
the detection is even lower than
accuracy of the vicar's comes a final
bqa answer i queasy so how can you
really get such a high IQ z to answer
the questions but based on a very poor
performance of object detection so I
think maybe there are two answers to
that I mean I think one answer that is
it turns out that a lot of
it's sort of a distribution of data
question it turns out that a lot of the
stuff that's in the scene graphs that
are ultimately come from visual Geno and
though we've normalized them is fairly
simple stuff right that there's a lot of
things that's talking about people and
fruits and cars and airplanes and so
there's a even though we do some things
to rebalance the data that I'll there
are sort of core concepts basic
categories if you will and psychological
terms that are used a lot and a much
fewer in number and so that helps I
think the other part of the ants so is
we don't have to get the answer exactly
right because of each point we're
putting an attention distribution across
the space of concepts and so to the
extent that the model roughly thinks
that oh it's probably one of these four
things and I don't know which the model
can place non-trivial attention over all
of those four things and reason forward
from there even though you know if it
was just guessing at random between them
then it'd only be getting 25% accuracy
we have some problems as we get sound
run object detection and then the models
a rizzoli model nurse for this run scene
so - something wrong with them impacts
final answer is correct just like
running running and design culture right
so we do not learn anything kind of we
do not learn that use for with the
meaning so there's plenty a chance of
getting things wrong but you know
there's also a chance that the sort of
multi-step reasoning could actually be
more human-like because I mean if you
sort of say a go-kart to the right of a
person well even if your go-cart
detector isn't that good if you know
it's to the right of a person well you
could say how that thing over there must
be a go-kart right and so the actual
relational reasoning can actually help
you do better and you want person behind
there so
it seems that there are two main
approaches to Montes the reason one is
you know explicit modular discrete
constructions versus you know having a
universal kind of continuous actions and
it seems that you have tried both of
them in put in two of your works one is
the maxim which is the universal cell as
opposed to your recent work which is
more like a discrete instructions so
from your experience which one of these
approaches you think would be more
foo-foo Brochu um yeah so I guess I'm
right at the moment I'll say the neuro
state machine because look it seems to
be working there but I think right so
there's clearly a wide open space of
approaches and it's not really clear
that I or anyone know the best approach
but right so in some sense the neural
state machine approach is sort of more
specific with us different things
compared to the Mac architecture but
it's still not as specific and custom as
something like the neural modular
networks right that it's still being
done as sort of there aren't special
units to do anything like spatial
reasoning or counting or anything like
that right that it's still doing a more
general attention based computation and
so in some sense I still see it as
similar to the Mac family I don't know
yeah
two singers no object detector no
relation particular just a gone through
synapse and use your architecture
right so the question is you're using a
vision system and there's an answer that
you should be able to get where you just
say here's the gold scene graph for this
scene run it on that and then you should
be really you're back in that state then
like you should be able to get a hundred
percent off of the question and the gold
scene graph no I don't have those
answers and you know that would be a
interesting thing to do I mean I think
clearly it had been much much higher
number right here there's sort of two
parts of this question and one of which
is what is the difficulty of the vision
problem of recognizing things and the
other one is how successful in you
actually reason across these scene
graphs questions from the NLP team and
Emma sorry I am okay Learning Team and
I'm uh sorry I because you're gonna be
with Chris over the next few are so
there any non MS or so if we combine
computer vision and healthy it's me QA
or gq8 and my background is yes art so
my question is really how can a SAR be
combined with life or do you think one
day we will be working on something like
combining all these three areas yes ours
to eat healthier
yes so yeah so I haven't done that so I
mean in you know I have nothing against
speech recognition of course in some
sense of speech recognition hasn't seen
the right place to play for trying to do
this higher-level reasoning I mean you
know on the one hand there's clearly a
connection right when humans are doing
speech recognition they have a much
higher level understanding of where they
are and what's being talked about
and they use that to help with their
speech recognition and you should be
able to do the same and so yes we should
be able to combine all of these
modalities together and do much more I
mean in practice
that's tended not to be what happens in
speech systems and the speech is
recognized to the word level before
anything else happens and to the extent
that that's true if you're sort of more
interested on sort of higher-level
reasoning incorporating in speech hasn't
seemed the easy ways to sort of make the
problem more interesting where I'm doing
multimodal work with vision has seen
much more approachable anyone on this
side of a question yes so you talked
about how the clever data set was
basically a very large amount of data
but like a very small space and so you
basically make a bigger version of that
in the form of gqa so what's the
intuition on how complex you want to
make this data sets so that these high
capacity models like don't actually
memorize it versus like actually learn
to reason on them yeah I mean I can so
say my thoughts but you know they they
sort of you know the usual kind of half
and form thoughts yeah so I mean I guess
and research somehow you want to find
the right sweet spot where there things
aren't too difficult but it presents the
right kind of challenges and questions
for what you want to pursue and you know
I guess my feeling coming into this was
that if you compared textual
question-answering first visual question
answering that even though there had
been progress every year and visual
question answering there's a way in
which the problem seemed sort of too
hard and too diverse so that where is
the textual question answering there's
been a really good ramp in fact in some
sense it might seem like it's almost too
easy with all of these results on
textual question answer
claiming better than human results on
squad and the data sets for visual
question answering it sort of seemed
like the space of questions and
knowledge and so on was sort of two
variegated and hard for the current
systems but on the other hand the blocks
world system seemed like they were too
small and too easy and so yeah we were
looking for something that was sort of
in the middle which presented reasoning
challenges over real vision problems but
is still sort of more constrained than
just saying Turco's come up with some
question to ask and you know at that
point you know it's a bit effectively
that you're betting that the this might
be a sort of an interesting level of
difficulty for people to explore for
working on scene understanding and you
know it can certainly be criticized
because our questions are still sort of
add artificial when it comes down to it
but we hope that they're sort of from a
broad enough space that it's actually an
interesting good challenge for
developing visual scene understanding
reasoning systems for a few years okay
that's not X keen yeah so in your
opinion what do you think is a role of
logical inferences it seems to me that
it might make sense for these models to
know that if something is black it could
not be read it is to the left of the
entities to the left of whatever the
transitive of left Ness and so on do you
think there is a role for not just a
logical infinity
so certainly there is a role for having
more understanding of domains and being
able to make use of that understanding
so I mean there's kept slightly more of
that than I sort of fully made clear
right so that we do sort of so by
construction so when I said there was a
space of concepts that we put into
taxonomy so we actually are exploiting
that texana me and this is sort of how
we have a kind of a hand done and
middlee hand done disentangled
representation so that we have sort of
taxonomic concepts like colors and so
then for color for the property of color
you'll have a tension distribution over
different colors so in a sort of a soft
way it is representing that the choice
of colors are complimentary from each
other so we are making some use of that
kind of information but there's
certainly a lot of other reasoning
information like sort of liver to the
left of and to the right of being
reverse its we aren't capturing so yeah
I think there is absolutely a role to be
doing more inference of a logical
character and future models
[Applause]